everyone welcome to today's webinar
looking at
uh the new gas chromatography from
agilent technologies
i'm ken brady i'm the marketing program
manager here in europe
for gas phase solutions i
we'd like to really tell a story uh
around
how we've developed our new product uh
what the product is
and some of the uh smart connected
self-aware technologies and accessories
that come with with
those new platforms agilent as you know
are by far the the
dominant manufacturer of gas
chromatographs we've been the innovation
leader
and the market leader for some time and
it's a market that we've been in for
over half a century and over that half
century
we've really i we've really changed how
grass gas chromatographs work and you
can see from this slide if we take a
look over the last 50 years
we came into a market where there hadn't
been much in the way of technological
development it really was a
new technique which was which was not
widely used
and as hewlett packard we
used the hewlett packard ethos and
the hewlett packard method of innovation
to develop easier to use
products hewlett packard were a company
that looked at ergonomics and
use of scientific instruments back in
the 60s and early 70s when it was an
alien concept from
for most companies using everyday
equipment
agilent have have continued that
innovation in the hewlett-packard way
and
and have really driven the innovation in
ways that that are demanded by our
customers
everything we do is really driven by the
feedback that our users and customers
give us
and nothing has changed so you can see
on on this side we started many many
years ago
uh with with the 5840 gc which was the
first microprocessor controlled gc
we've had innovations like the the first
automatic injector we have innovations
like
our like retention time locking which
really make things easier for our users
all the way up to 2016 when we launched
the interval
9000 gc and interval is a
step change in what gc can do i
will talk about that more as we go
through the presentations but in turbo
really
brought us to a point where we changed
gc and interval is not for everyone but
it brings a lot of usability
intelligence connectedness that doesn't
exist in scientific instruments
but really intubo is
is the pinnacle of what we can do with
gc
in turbo though is not ideal for every
application
and it's a step change maybe too far for
most users
we were in that we were at that stage
where we have all of those technologies
and all of that capability
we also have our our main platforms the
7890 and 7820 gcs and the 7890 gc is the
biggest selling gc ever made more widely
used than any gc
more flexible than any other gc
we want to replace the 7890 gc so how do
we do that what's the roadmap for for
developing a new product
so you can see from the slide on on this
pathway that we followed the first thing
we have to do is assess our customers
needs and assess the value of the
of the changes to a customer
we then define the scope we
design we test we engineer we we
manufacture that new product
and then we have to work out how we
support the changes to that product and
we go live and we start delivering those
products to you
and really the questions we have to ask
ourselves are
what do we do next what can we do next
what's possible
what would add value to you the user
what would be helpful
what would make your life special what
would make your life easier
and and then what would make that that
instrument would make that product
special enough for someone to want to
have that instead of the instrument they
have right now
on their bench so
the first thing we have to do is ask the
people who matter and those people are
are you our customers and users
we came to you you may know that you may
not know that you may have been part of
the uh
part of the the feedback sessions you
may
you may have given feedback that came to
steer the product development
but we we get the feedback we listen to
that feedback
and what you told us was that you you
wanted us to improve the user experience
you wanted the instrument to be easier
to install and set up
easier to use and maintain and to make
gas chromatography more practical for
today's lab environment where it's
really busy
and downtime is a real issue also
i you want us to prepare for the next
generation of gc users
some of our presenters on today's call
are younger than others
and some of them have different levels
of experience
i started working in laboratories when
we didn't
get to be specialists you didn't get to
work on one technique your whole life
i'm never going to be an expert in any
one technique
i don't have the experience of some of
our other speakers on gc
i have a broad knowledge but i don't
have the specialist techniques
i can't troubleshoot in the way that
some of our other speakers today can
and we are starting to see in
laboratories
more and more generalists and fewer
specialists and and you're asking us
to make an instrument that's easier for
people like me
and those generalist users to use that
fits in with what they do
that's recognizable and that can be
really uh easy to pick up without
reading a manual
the other feedback we had was that we've
developed new instruments and we've
brought new features to all of those new
instruments
the capability of the system has
grown faster than the usability and that
you have features on the systems that
you never use
because they're not easy to access or
easy to implement
you our customers have asked that is to
close that usability gap to make sure
that the features that exist
on the gas chromatograph actually can be
used on the gas chromatograph
without the expert knowledge that we
know is now becoming more dilute in
in every lab we also
uh go out to customers routinely and a
few years ago we had a massive lab
manager survey where we spoke to
thousands of lab managers across the
planet
and asked them what they wanted in new
instruments and what they needed from
agilent
and those lab managers shared their
feedback their challenges their
aspirations
and 58 of those cited business
efficiency and productivity as their
number one
number one business objective i imagine
most of them have it either an objective
but 58 percent cited it as their most
important objective
73 of those people recognize unplanned
downtime as their biggest
challenge i imagine 100 percent see it
as a challenge
but for three quarters of those people
it was the biggest challenge
and over half of those lab managers
see staff development as their number
one personal goal
so they want us to deliver instruments
that are easier for for the average user
to use and to and to deliver results
from
the other feedback we were given was
that there are some challenges facing
labs today and going into the future
and as i mentioned the the generation of
super users
are aging and retiring so the the skills
in laboratories are declining
not because people aren't clever or
aren't capable but because
everyone is a generalist that means that
the method development and
troubleshooting skills
are no longer easy to get hold of in
every laboratory at the instrument
so people need to grow their skills and
we have to help train operators to
assume those multiple responsibility
roles
but deliver results in the in the
laboratory with the instruments that are
there
so there's really a need for smarter
instruments with more
connectivity so that we can have remote
troubleshooting and remote development
without
without having any complexity on the
instrument
so where are we today we we know what we
want in an instrument we know how people
we know how people's experiences we know
what the desire of the lab manager is
but things have changed since we last
developed an instrument you know it's
close to a decade since the 7890 was
launched
things have changed in that time if we
look at things we use every day
like mobile phones you can see here how
mobile phones have changed over the last
two decades
we used to have no screens then we had
small screens and buttons
and then we had bigger screens and
smaller buttons and then we had
keyboards with more buttons and more
buttons and then we had the iphone and
the iphone changed
changed everything the the idea of a
touch screen with something that can be
changed with with an operating system
change and features can be brought in
just by adding an icon
if we look at the things that have
passed the things that have worked
things that failed the things that we
tend to
the things we tend to stick with and the
things we we embrace
really are the things that are the
easiest
to adapt to that give capability without
complexity
and uh and and the ease of use is
absolutely key
so we're in a situation where we're all
used to having
complex computers in our hands and
pockets and desks
but we use them in a way that's simple
without thinking and it's that
easy to adapt technology that really is
is making uh making our life different
and if we see how our lives are becoming
different
we're in a situation today where our
world is becoming
far far more connected and the smart
capability of things
is is increasing day by day most of us
will have
features that that were science fiction
20 years ago you know where we're living
where the smart home is a real thing
geo fencing uh heating and air
conditioning controls are
based on where your phone is the smart
car is becoming a reality i can
i can look at a map on my phone and i
get in my car and my car automatically
starts to start now to tell me how to
get there how to avoid traffic
when i'm going to arrive where i can get
fuel
things are changing in such a way that
smart capability and the connectivity
is changing our lives and making our
lives far far easier
so we're seeing now as being in in the
fourth industrial revolution
for us here in britain we talk about the
industrial revolution and that's seen as
the first industrial revolution where
mechanization
the use of steam power burning burning
coal and wood
to create to create power i gave us the
ability to
to really scale up manufacturing and
have this industrial scale manufacturing
the second industrial revolution really
was the onset of the production line and
mass production
uh henry ford uh bringing the the
repeat manufacturing and the volume
manufacturing that reduce
costs and makes makes things more
regular and and routine
then we had the third industrial
revolution really in the late 70s and
early 80s where computer control of
those production systems
meant that they could be far more
efficient and things become
far more uh far more easy to to get hold
of and lower cost
and now we're in the fourth industrial
revolution where digitally enabled
internet of things and and these digital
ecosystems
really are are changing how we interact
with things
and how how everything changes uh
from from the manufacturing the
development of new products
to the to the use of those products and
we see a similar trend in what we do
with gas chromatography and agilent
we see where we are right now as as our
fourth
gc revolution in the 80s and 90s
we we launched the the 5890 gc and the
5890 gc was a step change in technology
for gc
we had we had uh control for other
components we had computer control we
had a data system
and we had floppy disk drives so we
could move data around and we could move
electronic methods around
then we had in the 2000s the
6890 gc and the 1690 is based on is
based on the technology we had in the
5890 but it brought things like early
maintenance feedback
a retention time locking so you can
transfer methods across gcs
uh you can you can you can get same
results in different places
but with the with the maintenance
feedback we can see
counters that tell us when it's time to
change things but there's no
intelligence it's just based on the
number of uses
then with the 7890 i sorry the the 7890
and and the 8890 we have uh
more and more change right up to up
today within 2vo where we have
onboard dual core processors where we're
measuring
hundreds of different set points and we
have intelligent diagnostics
and a browser interface so we can see
those diagnostics remotely
and today we're we're looking back to
those
airbass ovens the 58 90 the 68 90 to
78.90
today we're talking about what comes
next and those
smart capabilities that we've talked
about the
the requirements of our lab managers and
our users
and what they want and what they need
and we have to deliver those
so we've been asked to let you spend
more time on what matters most
you'd ideally like instruments that are
more self-aware ideally able to
self-diagnose
with the capabilities we have with the
internet of things we can bring
an ecosystem with embedded sensors for
intelligent
diagnosis of problems we have real-time
processors so we can
evaluate those problems real time and we
have these smart algorithms and smart
consumables that
that make life easier for you that tell
you when you have problems and tell you
how to fix those problems
and the big surprise is we didn't bring
just
one of those as you can probably tell
from this slide
what i'd like to do now is hand over to
a colleague of mine brian white
brian is a product specialist here in
the uk
brian has many many many years of
experience
is an expert gastro chromatography user
and has been with agilent for some time
he's been in this industry for many
years
and has a long history of developing
intelligent
solutions and brian's going to tell you
an awful lot more about what we're
bringing
to the market thank you ken
so before i start on the 8890
and the 8860 the key thing here
is to look at the first
gc really that's made a big big
difference in how we
interact with our instrumentation so the
first gc's
that i used uh was 58 80 dc's
uh that's uh you see how long ago that
actually was
and if you look at the 5880 all the way
through the 58 19 the 68 19 and 78 90
yes
their performance definitively did
improve the accuracy of the epcs the
ability to get repeated reproducible
retention times etc
we got to 78.90 and really technically
there is nothing more that you actually
need from a gc
but the way that we actually interact
with our instrumentation hadn't actually
changed
in many decades and what was clearly
needed
from the new sort of range of gcs was
for them to be easier to use
they need to be smarter so that people
if the instrument itself would tell you
it wasn't producing the right answers
and obviously in this today's world uh
needs to be greener really if at all
possible
so the intuvo was developed uh
about two or three years ago and the
reason why i'm going to start on this is
because features here within the intuvo
are actually repeated on our airbus oven
equivalents
let's look at the intuvo the intubo
totally is redesigned really uh
completely how
gc is done and what we have here is
a instead of an airbath oven it's direct
heating it's a hot plate
and we have specific columns that fit
the column against
that hot plate so it's an
ever-increasing radius
but only one column thick now the
benefit of this is you can heat at 250
degrees c per minute throughout the
whole temperature range
and clearly this is the gc that we go to
where ease of use is paramount
because there's no cutting of columns no
fells needed here
but additional to that when uh fast
analysis is needed because if you can
heat up 250 degrees c per minute
and also call from 450 to 50 degrees c
in less than three minutes you can see
why this gc has some unique abilities
over and above that as well we have a
disposable guard chip because this
column can't be trimmed
so in traditional use of gc where you
have dirty matrix
being injected one classic way of
handling that
is to trim the column clearly in this
situation we can't do that but we have a
disposable guard chip
which is has a point eight of a meter of
flow path within it
that being independently heated allows
us to basically trap the matrix
on that and then backslash from that so
there are some unique things still about
the intuba that still needs to be
of interest here
so a completely different flow path
traditional flow pathway you see
normally of all gcs out there in the
marketplace you will see bits of
capillary column
uh at the base of the gc you see fells
everywhere you see
nuts everywhere it's never gcs don't
tend to be a neat place to be
on the intuvo flow path then we've got
rid of those nuts and fells and uh
we don't need to cut the columns
obviously it's a completely different
flow path
and we're making connections by uh
basically uh it's click and run
connections where
you're deforming the metal to make it so
it's actually inherently more gas
type than you'd ever get with a felt
so here's a description of how we're
actually making those connections
you see effectively it's by pushing one
metal against a softer metal
uh the softer metal here being the guard
chip
and it's a direct seal and it's it's
just so much easier to do
easier to train less unplanned downtime
you know basically as a lab manager that
your gc is going to be working first
time
now over to another feature of the
intuvo which is
applicable now to what we're discussing
primarily in this
webex this is the 88 1988-60 intelligent
airbath ovens
is the leak checking so we have the
latest generation of epc which is our
sixth generation epc module so you can
see that on the right hand side
and whenever we do any maintenance
because the gc knows exactly how it's
configured
it has the ability to do automatic leak
checking predominantly this is
incredibly valuable
so when you're actually changing even
something as simple as a liner
and you're putting a new liner in you
know it will automatically do that leak
check and you know as an operator
that as a result of you doing that
maintenance your analysis will not be
impacted
in fact it will you know it's going to
work first time and something silly
hasn't stopped you
losing an over the weekend run or an
overnight run
so this is about connectability so you
can connect to
any of our gcs now basically
uh with a a pad or a computer
or you don't even need to be on site if
you wish to do so
they each of the gcs have a dual core
processor
so as long as you're allowed on to the
local internet and you type in the ip
address of the gc you're logged straight
in and you're as if you are actually
controlling the dc
clearly this can be uh password
protected if anyone has concerns about
that
but what's really really nice here is
that you can connect in you can see
what's happening the gcs have
all of their instructions on how to use
them embedded within them
so if you are needed to basically
uh do any maintenance for instance
the instructions for that are there
so here's an example of that so you can
see effectively
you go in there you go maintenance
perform maintenance and go inlet
and if you have here replace liner you
can see it will tell you what tools are
needed
it will cool the gc down so you don't
burn your fingers
it will turn off the gas supply when
the areas that need to be cool are cool
it will then give you step step-by-step
instructions on how to do that
maintenance
and then once the maintenance is done i
you have now changed the liner in the
situation
it will do the leak tech like i've just
said previously
and then effectively it now has
automatically started
the timer which means that you know how
many injections are done down that liner
so when you actually need to change it
again so you can set
that maintenance timer and it obviously
depends on
what analysis you're doing but that
maintenance timer will then
tell you when the next liner should
actually be changed
so here we have uh basically example of
all the information you have as a user
at your fingertips
we have agilent university agilent.com
agilent gc community
if we go back to agilent university this
is a
really undervalued resource it's
absolutely excellent
so please just type in agilent
university
uh when you finish listening to uh webex
and
you will see what's there it's
instructions on technique it's not
really primarily
on our implementation as such it's more
about how to use a gc and how to
optimize
your method so please go and look at
that
so when it comes to
instrumentation and you've got
instrumentation in your lab and yes
occasionally it will go wrong
and when it goes wrong you're left with
having to get it fixed
so what you need to do is you actually
try and work out what's actually wrong
with the instrument
and you then phone up agilent
or your instrument supplier and you
basically
tell them what you think is wrong they
will
evaluate your evaluation your
interpretation of what's wrong
and they will then send out an engineer
and
hopefully that engineer will turn up
with the right part
clearly that's not really 21st century
as far as instrumentation is concerned
if you had a car go wrong
you wouldn't nowadays expect
basically the mechanic to be scratching
their head and trying part a to part
said
what do you expect to happen is for the
car computer
to tell them the mechanic exactly was
wrong so you know exactly what part to
fix
why shouldn't you expect that therefore
from your instrumentation in laboratory
with the new range of gcs whether it be
the intuvo
or the 8860 or the 8890 you have those
dual cure processors on board
and that means they're monitoring all
the settings so what you can actually do
is basically you've got a health report
that can be produced for many of these
gcs
and this will either be a proof that the
gc is working absolutely perfectly
or should there be a problem then
you can actually download that health
report onto a usb
and email that to agilent and we know
exactly what's wrong with your
instrument which means that you're going
to get
first-time fixes this speeds up
everything
for you the user and also for us
uh the supply of the instrumentation is
just basically a much
more modern way of going about uh fixing
instrumentation
and what we have also is on board the gc
is all about installation and
familiarization all about compliance
servers and
education we have all the training you
need actually on the gc
so when you did a firmware upgrade on
the 7890 for instance
this would be done in five minutes
because there's not an awful lot that's
going across
but when you do a firmware upgrade on
our new instrumentation
then that can take up to an hour because
the amount of information that's going
across
to the computer on board the gcs is is
quite significant
it's got all that training all the
pictures all the videos etc
all that actually embedded on the gc
so if you wanted to develop a new
air bath oven because you know
ultimately
some people need the flexibility of an
airbath oven
uh and the intuvo would not be basically
uh the right gc for everybody
where do we start well what we need then
is clearly
is we don't want to sacrifice the
performance of the 7890 as far as
uh repeatable heating is concerned that
oven
is well recognized out there as being
given excellent
repeatable heating as given by all the
retention time stability
that all our users are getting and
but we do also don't want to keep all of
the intelligent
and all the leak checking of the intuvo
so if we combine the two
in your mind this is where we will
actually end up with
as far as the 88 16 88 90 concerned
which are clearly
those two blue sheets there
so if you look at the 8860 gc which is
our mid-range offering
what we have here is advanced proven
technology
i mean by that is everything that's on
the enchuvo
for the connected abilities and being
able to connect in from
outside it's also the rugged and
reliability from the 7890
and the way to actually position the
8860 is where core routine applicability
meets ease of use
and it is the next powerful generation
of electronic
architecture
so as already said before it's got dual
core processor on board
for real-time checking and the
connection
the sixth generation epc that i
mentioned with the leak checking
from the in tuvo it supports two inlets
which can be a mixture of
switzerland as packed or cool on column
and three detectors at a time
so you can have three detectors on this
gc uh a mixture of
fids tcds ecds fpd's mpds and
msd and should you be doing gas sampling
you can have
up to three gas sampling valves and six
heated zones
so the 8860 uh
this is what the touchscreen looks like
it's very similar in its appearance to
the intuba so it's a
it's a color touch screen interface it's
like you get
on your phone so it's incredibly
responsive
it's not squishy it's a proper touch
screen
uh on the top there you see a flow path
configuration
and it tells you what the set points are
where the actuals are and next
if you go down from there you see the
real time results the chromatographic
lead
display and then there's also status
information should you want to monitor
any particular temperature setting
so we have the diagnostic tests so
you've got inlet testing so this is
really the key part of the whole gc's to
be fair the new gc so
if you're using it uh it would tell you
whether you can do a leak and
restriction test
so this means not only as a result of
putting a new column in
there isn't a leak but as a result of
putting a new column in there's still
flow
that's where the restriction test comes
in you've got a pressure decay test
split vent restriction test so
you actually uh in the past you'd have a
problem with
your tubing from your split vent getting
blocked and you didn't know that until
you
undid the undid it and checked whether
it was dirt in there
now they actually instrument with tests
and will tell you there's a problem
and if you look at the fid as well uh
fid jets were being changed when they
didn't need to be
here we have an fid get restriction test
and also we got a leakage current test
as well
so these are all very new features that
is unique to these new intelligent
instrumentation
so we have guided troubleshooting so
should there be an issue on the gc
it will tell you exactly what's
happening so you get an inlet pressure
shutdown
uh nothing new there other gcs are doing
that but however it will tell you if the
system is unstable
if there's installation inconsistencies
if there's
issues with the tray firmware there's
thermal faults configuration faults this
gc is intelligent
it has got that core processor on board
so as far as viewer interface is
concerned uh you've got diagnostics
troubleshooting
training and help and the best way to
actually get that to be fair if you see
the picture on the right hand side
that is a big touchscreen
tablet you can connect to the gc
so if you wanted to actually see a
bigger screen than what's actually on
this gc you can just connect a tablet to
it type in the ip address
and off you go and you've got all that
information on a bigger screen
information on a bigger screen this is a
really nice
way of actually using the 88
not everybody needs to have a computer
next to their instrumentation so in the
past
every instrument had a computer next to
them
for controlling the gc for integrating
for uh producing numbers effectively
calibrating producing numbers
if we have a computer on board with
sufficient memory to store
many years worth of data then clearly
one option is to actually
put the integration and calibration
uh onto the gc itself and if we do that
then you the you can actually then
control the gc
integrate and produce numbers from the
instrument which is ultimately
the way you bought the gc from any
particularly usefulness in
in academia situations where you have
many many users
and you may not want to compute an
export they just
basically want to do a simple analysis
and they just want to connect in
with their own computer do all the
calculation produce producer report
and take that report away with them so
this is just an option
and we call it da express clearly we
have other options which are
computer-based
for doing all the software and all the
integration and
calibration but this is just a novel
option that you have now with these new
intelligent gc's and
only really on the 8860 dc
this is what it looks like you can't
really see too much but if you go across
the top there we have methods
and then another tab is sequences then
another tab is da express
and within dxpress is where you get the
calibration and the analysis
and like say you can store unlimited
methods and sequences
and it's all served up within a browser
interface
so that's the 8860 but if we now look at
the 8890 this is
the premium gc out there on the market
now
when you when you are developing any
solution to go on any gc the first
gc you make sure that your solution
works on will be an agilent gc because
of our position in the marketplace and
the 8890 interacts with just about
any any gc thing you want to consider
there are no limitations for this
instrumentation
so what we have is powerful next
generation architecture
similar to the 8860 but what you can see
there is a bigger
uh screen this is a seven inch color
touch display
we have spark connected functionality
the full suite of inlets
and you can have six valve eight heated
zones
it's got the next generation epc again
from the intuvo
and you what you notice there is a smart
key so below the touch screen there's an
area there
and remember the smart keys from the
intuvo where
they actually when you plug in a column
it tells the gc exactly what the column
is
and what the dimensions are what the top
temperature is but this is where you can
buy columns now which are 88 90
applicable and you can basically have
those smart keys pull it into the gc and
the gc knows exactly what's happening
so the 8890 gc has
uh again it's a 7-inch color screen
where you can see the configuration
status methods
sequence troubleshooting diagnostics and
help it's very similar to the 8860 but
obviously on the bigger screen
and real-time chromatographic evaluation
blank evaluation
detector evaluation and those smart keys
which are
unique to now to the intubo and to the
8890
so let's look into the browser interface
uh for all of these gc's in a little bit
more detail
so here we have on the left hand side an
example of
a status and this is basically a dual
channel system
quite clearly with an f id and an npd
and you can see the temperatures and the
flow rates that are currently happening
on the instrumentation
and then if you go on the right hand
side this is uh you can actually put
methods straight into the gc should you
require it
or this would be obviously if you don't
have a data system next to the
instrument
or a limb system etc but still
and here we are if you want to actually
run a sequence from the gc you can see
you can
cut and paste lines this is not like in
the pathway
you basically start on line one that's
file one to file nine using method x now
you can actually
interact with the gc directly just as
you would do from a data system should
you wish to do it this way
and you can inject from vial 9 using
method a and from file
15 using method b for instance total
flexibility
cut and paste and uh copy on all those
lines
and then and then maintenance from the
right hand side this
is really well i mentioned earlier where
the gc will automatically
start the timer should you do any
maintenance through the system
by that i mean sector liners changing
columns a number of things
and as an experienced user in the lab
you'll know how many injections you can
get down that system
before the juice before any of those
should be changed
and so therefore what we have here is
incorporated a maintenance
timer which will highlight to you uh any
more inexperienced user when let's say a
liner should be changed
which will basically mean that that will
change before you get a problem
which is what we're trying to achieve
here is uh more uptime and less
issues diagnosing what's gone wrong
so as far as diagnostics is concerned
this diagnostics page on the left hand
side
is always checking its systems and it
can self-diagnose what's actually wrong
with it
and on the here on the right hand side
this example of a help page
and here's a wealth of information at
your fingertips
uh including tutorials troubled shooter
troubleshooting
and much so this is actually embedded
within the gc
so you can go in there and it will tell
you how to use itself
so how do we position our three
gc's to you the user
so the best way of looking at this is
the intuvo
which would be our first really
intelligent gc that we've launched into
the marketplace a couple years ago now
is where ultimate ease of use meets the
highest productivity
especially if you're considered with
mass spec as well
i would add to that that is our go-to
instrument when we want to do
extremely fast chromatography
the 8860 is incredibly
good performing excellent instrument
really where
core routine applicability meets ease of
use
and then if you want uh total
flexibility
and performance that's where the 8890
sits in